80% of us families have not purchased a
book this year my question to you is how
intentional are you being about your
growth and about improving your
strengths Talent multiplied by
investment equals strength here's the
breakdown Proverbs 4:7 says the
beginning of wisdom is this get wisdom
though it costs you all you have get
understanding a big mistake we can make
is trying to be somebody else and
actually playing to our weaknesses
instead of our
strengths what if I told you that the
Bible is the greatest success book of
all time and that hidden in these pages
are secrets for online business for
marketing for even YouTube well it's
true and in this episode of the think
media podcast I'm going to be talking
about three big ideas and a whole bunch
of Bible verses that every Christian
content creator needs to know and
specifically we're going to be covering
tips for finding and grow growing your
audience wisdom from the Bible on how to
multiply success in all areas including
business and YouTube and the biblical
shortcut for growing your YouTube
channel and your online business now
today's episode of the think media
podcast is brought to you by expand
Goods kingdom.com if you didn't know we
have a brand new class for Christian
content creators it's entirely free but
that's in the show notes and I'll tell
you a little bit more about that later
so let's dive into the show so here's
the first big idea from the Bible that
every Christian content creator needs to
know play to your strengths 1 Peter 4:10
says each of you should use whatever
gift you have received to serve others
as faithful stewards of God's grace in
its various forms you've got a unique
gift you've got unique abilities God has
woven greatness into your DNA but a huge
mistake that we can make is looking at
somebody else's gift that we don't have
and getting jealous a big mistake we can
make is trying to be somebody else and
actually playing to our weaknesses
instead of our strengths what's exciting
is that the opportunity we have on
YouTube is to use the gifts God has
given us just as it says in First Peter
each of you should use the gift you've
received to serve others what a mission
statement for our YouTube channels use
the gift that you've receed received
your talents your experience the wisdom
you've gained and serve others and this
platform called YouTube gives us that
opportunity you know you win games with
your strengths not your weaknesses and
it actually reminds me of a famous book
called strengths finder
2.0 one thing that every Christian
content creator needs to do is identify
your zone of Genius you got to identify
your strengths I've heard it said that
God Graces you where he places you like
you have a unique Grace for certain
things and you don't have a Grace for
other things like for me you don't want
to put me on a stage with a guitar
singing music and singing songs like
that's not my grace like for me you
don't want to put me in certain
environments like highlevel Athletics
like I I kind of run around the block a
few times daily but then I put the block
back under my bed like as a real athlete
that's not going to be my my grace zone
so you want to Find Your Grace Zone and
I love this book it's a classic book and
here's a quote from Tom wrath it says
this far too many people spend a
lifetime headed in the wrong direction
they go not only from the cradle to the
cubicle but then to the casket without
uncovering their greatest talents and
potential the key to human development
is building on who you already are the
key to human development is building on
who you already are what are your
strength what's unique about your
personality one of the keys to
succeeding on YouTube is authenticity
have you ever watched a crater when you
could just tell they're a little bit
different I don't love everything about
their personality but they're
comfortable in their own skin I can tell
that they are who they are they're being
themselves they're
expressing who they really are have you
also seen other creators that maybe felt
like they just feel a little fake they
feel like they're maybe trying to be
somebody that they aren't and that
content doesn't resonate with us so
there's something powerful about playing
to our strengths and it actually reminds
me about the story of David going to
fight Goliath and you know I've been
reading this book to my three-year-old
at Knight young Shawn Bradley and we're
reading this story of David versus
Goliath and there's a part in the story
where King Saul finally agrees to let
David go and fight Goliath and he says
here try on my armor so David puts on
the the helmet and the breastplate and
the shield and the sword and he realizes
this stuff doesn't fit this isn't
something I'm comfortable with this
isn't something I've practiced or
trained with this isn't me so he takes
off the armor goes down to a stream
picks out five smooth Stones which he
had experience using a slingshot he was
comfortable and familiar with that
particular method of warfare what does
the story reveal it reveals the only way
for David to contribute his best to the
cause was to be authentically himself
you know Saul's armor represented wealth
power and the latest technology while
David sling represented Simplicity and
vulnerability now each of those rightly
understood is a gift from God if your
greatest skill set is the money that you
have to Steward and the power that you
have to Steward and using the latest
tech and the fanciest gear stuff's not
bad rightly understood that's a gift
from God but that didn't fit David for
David it was about Simplicity and
vulnerability and that is what was used
to Advanced God's Kingdom so what does
that mean for you and I we have to play
to our strengths what assets what
resources what strengths do you have
don't worry about the things you don't
have or trying to wear Saul's armor
figure out your five smooth Stones your
sling and play to your strengths but big
idea number two is this you got to keep
growing and improving your strengths
here's the verse Luke 2:52 says and
Jesus increased in wisdom in Broad and
full understanding and in stature and
years and in favor with God and man this
verse is wild to me because Jesus who
was fully God and fully man wasn't born
into the world with Peak wisdom Peak
favor with everybody else Peak skills
Jesus actually had to grow and Jesus
living his life on this Earth by the
limitations of a man living on this
Earth filled with the spirit of God
eventually and the power of God went
through a process of growth in maturity
so he actually increased and grew in
wisdom he actually grew in stature so he
got taller he actually grew in his
muscular structure he had to eat and
exercise and work out and he grew in
favor with God and man what does that
tell us it tells us that we can't just
rely on whatever our natural gifts and
talents are but that we have to be
committed to personal development we got
to keep growing we got to identify our
strengths but then we need to improve
our strengths and you know literacy
inc.co revealed some really shocking
stats check these out 56% of young
people claim they read fewer than 10
books per year 50% of us adults are
unable to read an eighth grade level
book 30 33% of us high school graduates
never read a book after high school and
80% of us families have not purchased a
book this year my question to you is how
intentional are you being about your
growth and about improving your
strengths I understand there's other
ways to learn besides books I know we
live in a world of podcasts and audio
books and online courses and all of
these options but these stats are kind
of sobering because it reveals that the
majority of people are not continuing to
grow but they've settled that the
improve but they've settled and if you
want to have success as a content
creator let me encourage you that in the
pages of the Bible we discover God
charging us and encouraging us
commanding us and living by example in
Jesus Christ showing us that we got to
be committed to growing in wisdom you
know when we find that story in Luke 2
we find that Jesus was in the Temple
asking questions I've learned that the
quality of the answers we receive in
life are based on the quality of
questions that we ask are you asking
questions and searching out answers in a
library or on amazon.com searching out
answers on YouTube to solve specific
questions about growth about marketing
about best practices on YouTube about
building an online business when the
student is ready the teacher appears I
am fascinated that Jesus who had access
to the infinite knowledge of the
universe was being mentored and was
asking questions could it be that God is
encouraging you and I to be students to
be disciples to be Learners and to be
people that continue to grow and develop
our strengths in second Peter chapter 1
the author lists out a list of qualities
including faith and brotherly love and
brotherly kindness and then second Peter
1 18 says this for if you possess these
qualities in increasing measure they
will keep you from being ineffective and
unproductive in your knowledge of the
Lord Jesus Christ so in that verse it
says not just you have love or you have
faith but it says if you have these
qualities and you keep leveling them up
if you've got these qualities but you're
improving these qualities and you
continue to grow then you will be
effective and it'll keep you from being
unproductive again we see this theme in
1 Samuel 17 34-35 David said to Saul
your servant has been keeping his
father's sheep and when a lion or bear
came and carried off the sheep from the
flock I went after it struck it and
rescued the sheep from its mouth so we
see that David even though he was born
with a particular set of skills and a
particular set of talents or abilities
he was able to face Goliath with
confidence because he had practiced and
improved his strengths by by fighting
lions by fighting bearss by protecting
sheep so when the day of opportunity was
presented to him he was able to face
Goliath with confidence he was able to
know that his accuracy with the stone
and the sling was something that he
could count on it wasn't like he was
like man I hope this works that day no
he had spent a lifetime preparing so
that when opportunity arose he was ready
for it friend we have to have a
commitment to continue to grow and to
continue to improve our strengths if we
want to succeed on YouTube we got to
keep learning keep growing keep studying
and keep sharpening our skills and back
to strengths finder 2.0 Tom wrath said
this building your talents into real
strengths requires practice and hard
work much like it does to build physical
strengths so what are your top strengths
and how can you continue to improve
those you know I've found that as a
communicator I've been communicating for
a lot of years on stages on podcasts on
videos and even though I've been
studying communication for over 20 years
now I continue to study communication
getting mentored interviewing experts
buying materials buying books it's
something about having a beginner's
mentality that even if you already are
arguably an expert even if you already
have experience continue to practice and
continuing to work on your strengths and
improve them Tom wrath actually has a
formula for Success Talent times
investment equals strength let me say it
again Talent multiplied by investment
equals strength here's the breakdown
Talent is a natural way of thinking
feeling or behaving investment is time
spent practicing developing your skills
and building your knowledge base and
that equals strength and here's the
definition of strength the ability to
consistently provide near perfect
performance wow the ability to
performance strengths don't happen by
accident your raw strengths still need
to be developed your raw talents still
need to be developed so that you can
consistently provide near-perfect
performance I believe that's possible
for you and me but it's on the other
side of putting in the work Tom wrath
says the most successful people start
with dominant Talent so number one what
is your dominant Talent what are those
raw gifts God has given you uncover
those develop those the most successful
people start with dominant
talent and then add skills knowledge and
practice to the mix when they do this
the Raw Talent actually serves as as a
multiplier so big idea number one Play
to your strengths big idea number two
keep growing and improving your
strengths and big idea number three buy
wisdom and go faster this is the
biblical shortcut to earning more money
and making a greater impact here's the
verse proverbs 4:7 says the beginning of
wisdom is this get wisdom though it
costs you all you have get understanding
in the message's paraphrase it actually
says it like this sell everything and
buy wisdom man I love this verse here in
the pages of scripture we see a recipe
for Speed if we want to go faster if we
want to make a greater impact if we have
an Endeavor I want to build an online
business I want to build a successful
YouTube channel I want to work from home
I want to promote my church or my
Ministry and impact more people there's
something that we are trying to
accomplish scripture would encourage us
to sell everything and buy wisdom so
that we could accomplish that thing
faster and when I think about it saying
invest in truth and invest in wisdom
there's multiple different ways we can
invest there's really four primary
resources that we have one is money of
course we could exchange money for a
book learn something in the book and
ultimately go faster like if you are
lacking Clarity on your strengths there
is an assessment in strengths finder
that will you just answer the questions
and it'll help you have more clarity on
your strengths rather than sitting alone
disconnected from wisdom or community
and just trying to figure things out you
could spend a little bit of money and
you ultimately could get Fierce clarity
about your strengths and then you could
double down on those but money is only
one of the resources that we can invest
there's also our time so if we're saying
bu wisdom you know ultimately how we
spend our time is basically the same as
how we spend money I mean we trade our
time for money and if we're not working
we're trading our time for rest and
relaxation or for entertainment or for
novelty and so we can invest our money
we can invest our time we also can
invest our attention and when I think
about our attention I've been hearing
that a lot for my wife lately she's
talking about Sean you're on your phone
and I want you to be present with me and
the kids and a lot of times me being on
my phone is just actually me listening
to a podcast or a YouTube video audio
only but here's what it's doing it is
taking my attention so I thought man I'm
addicted to learning I'm addicted to
information I'm addicted to YouTube
honestly but that's my attention and so
what are you giving your attention to is
your attention going to negative news or
is it going to positive content and
Proverbs that are helping you get wiser
sharper and smarter rest and relaxation
and Leisure are incredible things but
scripture gives us a promise and an
opportunity that if we will buy wisdom
and understanding the benefits are many
wealth honor long life impact those are
all promised in Proverbs how about
investing in relationships you know
Proverbs 13:20 says walk with the wise
and become wise associate with fools and
get into trouble and so you can buy
wisdom to go faster by who you choose to
spend time with you can buy a plane
ticket and fly to an event or a Men's
Conference or a gathering or a
mastermind and leave an entirely
different person or you can hang out
with some fools and have their influence
ultimately pull you down what are you
investing in Proverbs 3:14 says wisdom
is worth more than silver it makes you
richer than gold wisdom is more valuable
than precious jewels nothing you want
compared to her in her right hand wisdom
holds long life and in her left hand are
wealth and honor so let me ask you a
question if we studied your calendar and
your checkbook or we studied your
calendar and your credit card statement
would it reveal that you value wisdom
like if we really looked at your
calendar and we looked at your credit
card statement or your debit card
statement would we see purch purches and
transactions and habits and routines
that identify that you are prizing
wisdom more than even money prizing
wisdom more than gold and silver that
you're parting with your money to get
wisdom that you're investing in travel
or experiences or resources or
relationships that are leading you down
the path of wisdom or are you in
investing in entertainment and Leisure
and Recreation and there's no judgment
coming your way on this podcast I just
want to encourage you that hidden in the
pages of scripture is a Biblical
shortcut to earning more money to making
a greater impact to having the YouTube
channel that you dream of to having the
online business that you ultimately want
to build but it doesn't happen by
accident it happens with intentionality
there's a difference between hanging out
with a positive influence and a negative
influence if you're talking with
Achievers and dreamers and action takers
don't be surprised when you start seeing
bigger dreams more action and more
achievement happen in your own life and
one of the verses of the Year here at
think media a few years back is
Ecclesiastes 10:10 and it says this
using adult acts requires great strength
so sharpen the blade that's the value of
wisdom it helps you succeed you see
wisdom helps you shift from primarily
working hard to also work working smart
we could go on and on about how many
verses in the Bible there are about hard
work but there's a lot of people that
work hard but still struggle in getting
results see using adult ax requires
great strength you're trying to cut down
a tree it's exhausting I grew up on six
acres in Arlington Washington we had
horses we had goats we had many dogs and
a few cats and we also would split
firewood our primary method of heating
our home was our wood fire stove Winters
in Washington were incredibly chilling
and so I would often times find myself
outside with a splitting Mall splitting
firewood and one of the things I learned
was that how sharp the blade was also
based on how dry or freshh the wood was
had a lot to do with how challenging
splitting that firewood was and taking a
little bit of time to sharpen the blade
before just going out and just putting
in massive effort and all of the muscles
and I'm sweating and I'm huffing and I'm
puffing and I'm exhausted see
Ecclesiastes it's got that wisdom
observed in the natural world and
applied to this context of if you want
to achieve something so if you're using
a doll ax man you're exhausted it's
tiring I'm trying to grow my YouTube
channel I'm exhausted I'm frustrated I'm
putting on all this effort it's not
working what's wrong here why why is
this not working why is my growth so
slow why is this not resonating the
writer of Ecclesiastes King Solomon
would encourage so slow down stop just
swinging the blade just going crazy all
this effort all this action all this
hard work sharpen the blade see that's
the value of wisdom it helps you succeed
I want to encourage you that over this
next year if you want to go faster you
want to take a
shortcut it's really more of a smart cut
because it's still going to take work
patience time and effort but you don't
need to spend 40 years wandering in the
desert when the journey is only 11 days
wisdom will get you there there faster
so I want to encourage you to play to
your strengths I want to encourage you
to keep growing and improving your
strengths and I want to encourage you to
pursue wisdom buy wisdom because it'll
help you go faster it is the biblical
shortcut to earning more money and
making a greater impact and if you like
this episode of the think media podcast
I also want to encourage you I think
you'll love expand God's kingdom.com at
that link which is in the show notes or
you can just type it into any browser is
a 1hour deep dive training let me be
honest it's longer than an hour because
once I get going it's packed full of
strategies and tactics and scriptures
very specifically tailored for Christian
content creators that want to build a
successful YouTube channel you know I've
been on YouTube for 17 years I've been
doing video for 20 I got started in my
local church doing video and I'm a huge
Bible nerd and I'm super passionate
about purpose-- driven people like you
getting their message out there and
impacct the world using the powerful
tool called YouTube so if that sounds
interesting to you I encourage you to
watch that next if you liked this
episode rate and review the podcast if
you listen on audio smash like and let
me know some feedback in the comments if
you listen or watch on YouTube and uh
check out that free class expand goods
kingdom.com and I will see you in a
future episode